um okay this you're i hope that people
understand the multiple layers of this
clip that i'm going to play for you um
some of you i know follow ufc ultimate
fighting championship which is a an mma
league a mixed martial arts league or
tournament but i don't know if they call
themselves a league or you know event
organizing organization um one of those
fighters a guy named bryce mitchell
delivered a completely delusional right
wing rant the other day
and
we're going to look at the rant because
the rant itself is totally wacky but the
other thing that i want to mention is
donald trump jr
retweeted it and said i'm with him now i
just want to remind you guys of the
absurdity of all of these right-wingers
who say athletes should just be athletes
shut up and dribble this type of thing
when they don't like lebron james's
activism or they don't like colin
kaepernick or
an olympic athlete or whatever making a
political point that they don't like
they say these you got to keep this
stuff these are just athletes at the end
of the day they should just be doing
their sport
but when you see a guy like bryce
mitchell deliver a delusional right wing
rant don jr all of a sudden loves it now
there are so many
prototypical
fallacies and red herrings here
that it's it's like a master class in
lack of critical thinking so let's just
start and then we'll we'll analyze as we
go well i just wanted to get your
thoughts on the whole russia and ukraine
situation
you know um
here's my first starters i'm not going
nowhere to fight none of these wars for
these politicians i'm staying at home
and when the war comes to arkansas i
will dig my boots in the ground and i
will die for everything i love okay now
that's totally fine i'm actually fine
with that and but now remember joe biden
has said he's not sending troops to
ukraine anyway also the idea that people
are going to invade arkansas i mean i'm
not making fun of arkansas but arkans if
he's like well i'm from arkansas i'm
just here to defend arkansas it's
unlikely just
statistically when you consider what are
the economic centers etc that arkansas
is going to be the front line but that
doesn't matter so far fine he's not
going to get involved he doesn't want to
fight the war fight i'm with you i will
not retreat okay this country is invaded
and everybody's saying well we gotta we
gotta evacuate we gotta leave we got i
will not i will dig my boots in the
arkansas soil and i will fight for the
people that i love for the land that i
love and the way life that i love but
i'm not going overseas to fight
i don't know what's going on to be
honest brother i really okay so he
admits he doesn't know what's going on
good that good
there's so much stuff and i don't think
nobody knows what's going on oh but okay
so now is where we start to get to this
trope
i don't think anyone knows what's going
on it's so complicated
nobody can know what's going on and this
is a typical thing that you hear
from i mean listen we've seen these
vaccines i mean syringes mrna
uh a polyethylene glycol the virus it's
sequence but from a lab or not
i don't think anyone really understands
it well no no no
you might not understand it but people
do understand stuff look there's this
invisible air that we breathe but it's
got oxygen in it nitrogen co2 i don't
think anyone really understands which of
these elements do we really need to
survive no actually we do know that
we actually you might not know it so
this is where it starts to get a little
bit fallacious and then
so remember he said he doesn't know
what's going on and nobody knows what's
going on let's continue holy there's
been so much political corruption in
that area you got biden and his son
making a [ __ ] ton of money well wait
hold on a second wait a second if you
don't know what's going on
and you just aren't sure of what's
happening
then why are you repeating
right wing conspiracies about joe biden
personally making money from from the so
it sounds like now you're asserting you
do know what's going on
off of uh and using our tax dollars to
bribe
their people that's treasonous in my
opinion
so he goes from
i don't know what's going on and i don't
want to get involved
to biden
committed treason
by using u.s tax dollars to bribe
someone
wait a second i thought you said you
didn't know what was going on bryce
uh so you got hunter biden and his son
using our tax dollars hey if
by the way
hunter biden's son i'm guessing he means
joe biden he doesn't even know the
talking points hunter i didn't even this
is the does hunter biden even have a son
i guess he does i don't i don't i mean
he's such a non-factor i don't even know
whether hunter biden has kids but i've
certainly never heard that they're
involved in the conspiracy ukrainian
government if you don't do this we're
taking your tax dollars he shouldn't be
giving our tax dollars to that country
anyway now what's really funny is
if you want to by the way for a guy who
doesn't know anything surely expressing
a lot of opinions if what's funny about
this is
if if you don't think things should be
held over the head of ukraine
trump
wanted to withhold military aid until
such time that ukraine got him dirt on
biden and thanks to colonel vinman and
others trump ultimately had to release
the military aid to ukraine this guy's
criticism which he claims i don't know
anything and now he's making about it
actually applies to trump think about
how backwards everything is here
veterans out here sleeping on a street
and you're gonna give our freaking tax
dollars to these ukrainians and all i'd
rather i don't know what's going on over
there but i'm not going over there and
fighting and god bless anybody that's
over there's fighting and i hope that
this just gets solved and man i don't
like war
you know what i mean i don't want people
dying and all that stuff i don't want to
be but i don't know what's going on
there's so much stuff that i think
that's corrupted that we just don't know
what for a guy who says i don't know and
we don't know he sure has a whole hell
of a lot of opinions and of course he
was spreading all sorts of
misinformation here and then he was
called out for it and then he was his
reaction to uh to that dude
you were recently on the mma hour what
was the reception to that interview like
oh i'm sorry this is him reacting to uh
from what he said on the mma hour okay
all the ariel helwani's yeah well he
kind of he didn't completely censor me
but he put that i was spreading
misinformation and
um
i don't know you know i thought
i i said a lot of true stuff and
but
it's open to a debate and
you know um
i love the second amendment and i love
the first and you know why we have the
first because we have a second yeah and
so that's a classic uh classic gun gun
uh gun person uh cl claim um
when someone writes an article saying
you spread misinformation
uh about what you said on a podcast the
first amendment just isn't a factor it
just has nothing to do with government
censorship of speech and so you know my
view is i don't have any particular
there some people say athletes should
talk about politics and others say they
shouldn't the equivalent of shut up and
dribble
i think anyone should say what's on
their mind
in whatever venue they deem appropriate
and if people don't like it they can
respond to that and say i'm not going to
patronize this or that or i'm not going
to pay for tickets to see whatever
but
whatever you say is subject to review
and to criticism and i've heard
interesting things said by athletes
before what this guy is saying is just
utter and complete nonsense and he's
welcome on the program anytime to
discuss any of these topics we'll have
the clip on instagram at david pakman's
show if you're just listening today it
is worth watching it rather than just
listening
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving showerhead starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just 119 but nebia
is giving you 10 off when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video